you know really the fall of my senior
year I found myself really for the first
time in a complete funk as I tried to
figure out what I wanted to do with with
my life and and also as I tried to
figure out my thesis topic but there
were a number of things going on in my
head one I'd been really focused on this
issue of educational and equity just the
fact that where you're born in our
country does so much to determine your
educational outcomes and of course in
turn your life prospects and as a public
policy major and really just a concerned
college student I was thinking a lot
about that issue organized a conference
about it that brought together college
students with kind of leaders from
across the country to think about what
can we do to improve our education
system and one day that that concern
just came together with my own search
for what I really wanted to do after I
graduated and I just thought you know
why aren't we being recruited as
aggressively to teach in low-income
communities as we were being recruited
at the time to work on a Wall Street
supposedly our generation was the me
generation and all we wanted to do was
go work for these 2-year corporate
training programs which I thought was
great for people who really wanted to do
that but ultimately I just thought that
the label the Me Generation was wrong it
wasn't that that's all we wanted to do
is that those were the only people
recruiting us so that was where the idea
of Teach for America came from and it
became the perfect answer to my thesis
dilemma
you know I would say that I had a number
of things going for me with this
particular big idea
one was that one was was the timing I
mean truly there really was a mood among
college seniors where that was just
conducive to this there was a tremendous
need in school districts which were
experiencing significant teacher
shortages and you know my senior spring
there was a front-page article in
Fortune magazine saying that corporate
America was gonna take on education
reform so there were so many elements
that made the timing for this perfect
the other thing is I say this all the
time my greatest asset was my
inexperience my complete naivete I was
convinced that this both had to happen
and could happen that it had to start on
a significant scale right from the start
and really no one was gonna talk me out
of this like people would tell me how
crazy this was and I would just not
really hear it and I think that was
truly one of the one of my biggest
assets the other thing is that I think
this particular idea was one that just
very quickly magnetized just thousands
of people really who who really
identified with the values on which it
was built and and just thought it made
sense you know from college students who
did in fact you know 2,500 recent
college graduates that you know in four
months responded to a grassroots
recruitment campaign which at the time
was Flyers under doors you know the
folks in corporate America who were
quoted in that article actually came
through with seed grants and ultimately
was significant support so you know in
the first year alone corporations and
foundations donated two and a half
million dollars to make it possible and
and and there was tremendous support in
the education community as well in
school districts from central
administrators from school principals
from veteran teachers who were honestly
inspired by this outpouring of idealism
from from this generation and wanted to
be a part of it so I think we had a lot
going for us in that initial year